a mountain lion is on its way back to
the wild after it decided to venture
into a summerlin neighborhood earlier
today
it made for quite the show for some in
the area orco mana spoke to a family who
was surprised by an
up-close encounter he joins us live now
with all the latest details orco
sasha after hours of roaming in the
neighborhoods here in the summerlin area
the
mountain lion was found here in front of
this home it was actually right here on
the front porch
police say luckily no one was injured
but it was still quite a shock to
everyone who saw it
videos and photos show the mountain lion
walking in between homes
police say they first got a call about a
mountain lion in the area of ulta
and fox hill drives around six this
morning but when officers
showed up the mountain lion got away it
was spotted again
around noon when it seemed to be hot and
tired police and
animal control were able to contain it
to a backyard and the nevada department
of wildlife tranquilized it
it still made its way to the front porch
after it was tranquilized but after it
stopped moving it was transported away
we spoke to a father and daughter who
were just going for a walk when they
came face to face with the wild animal
we looked to our left and this enormous
mountain lion was coming down the fence
line
stopped and looked at us and for the
first time
abby is my daughter abby and i felt real
fear
and that's when people were up on the
balconies
yelling at us to try to get out of there
we were really scared
once i realized when i started looking
left and right and realized that there
was fence on both sides of us
i got really worried and the lion was
going that way
and then we kept walking for about 10
minutes trying to find a way out
definitely not what you'd expect to see
when spending some father-daughter time
police tell us the mountain lion is
doing fine and will be released into the
wild
now if you ever spot a mountain lion or
another wild animal in your neighborhood
you're told to call 911 officers also
say the best thing to do if you can
is just go inside reporting live near
summerlin tonight orco mana 8 news now